we love people who are pillars of
positivity in their communities
i'm going to tell you something the
woman we're about to meet has blown my
mind i'm so excited to meet her and when
you hear
what she does i think you're going to
fall as in love with her as i have
okay we're going to team up with the
lego group to shine a light on a drew
gooder she's from philadelphia please
meet tashona
hey guys my name is tashon nathaniel
born and raised in philadelphia
i'm a single mother of three i work
night shift at saint christopher's
hospital and i am the founder and owner
of wickedberry seafood i started
wickedberry seafood about three years
ago right now is operating out of a
small kitchen but my community has
supported me and has gotten me to this
point in philly our slogan is the city
of brotherly love so i just want to give
back that love
it was taking some of the proceeds of
each cell and putting it towards a cause
that really was close to home last year
we did thanksgiving and we fed over 200
people at a women and family shelter and
this year we did a book bag drive
my boys they have been the biggest
supporters they also helped me load
cases of water for our book bag drive
they were out there helping you have to
serve your community so my dream for
wicked berry seafood is to have its very
own brick and mortar and with that i'll
have more proceeds with a bigger
outreach and if i can be a beacon of
hope and light in this world in my city
that's what i want to be
now
i am so excited to meet this woman um to
shauna are you there hello
hey drew
i gotta admit i think i'm what they call
star struck by you i want to share a
little stat about to shauna's life
um you work at 11 p.m uh to 7 30 a.m
yes
you're uh you pick your kids up and you
get them to school you sleep about two
or three hours
um
at around 1 30 you pick up your daughter
and then the rest of the kids
you work in the evening um you make
dinner for the kids until about 8 pm
then they go to your parents house and
you shower and you go to work starting
that 11 to 7
shift
how are you doing all this i have a
wonderful support system
my family is the biggest support system
so i'm really blessed to have my mom my
dad my sisters and my brothers all
support me on this journey and if i you
know need to get a couple hours i can
say hey mom can you please you know can
i get a couple more hours of sleep and
she's like okay okay
so definitely my tribe
they really helped me
i am who i am because of my trust
now we sent you and your family a bunch
of lego sets and i thought it would be
fun if we could both build stars
together while we chat
um okay now you've lived in the mount
airy neighborhood in philadelphia all
your life and
uh i would love to hear about why you
think it is so important to give back to
the community that you grew up in and
are still living in
growing up in that community is very
tight-knit
and a lot of opportunities were from
that community so i feel like
my teachers
um
counselors
uh store shop owners they all kind of
like took a chance on me where they
would hire me
or
they
knew what knew our family so they would
be really into our family like oh this
is a gr good good family this is a good
group so they always looked out for us
so i want to do the same thing for my
community i want to be the person that
you know gives that kid that inspiration
or that leeway and saying okay
a really good answer and you did some
amazing things with foster children
recently will you also tell me about
that
yes so uh i usually do something every
year really big and this year i said you
know what i want to do something big but
i really didn't though
so i came across the statistic that said
foster children have 10 minutes and a
trash bag to kind of like put their
stuff together and
go to placement so i was like oh no
this is and it was a calling something
was like this is what i want you to do
so i said you know what i called a
couple of friends i'm like i i don't
know how to do it but i want to do it
and i just wanted to get suitcases
filled with pajamas and and anything
else a child would need to have that
substance like hey this is mine not just
a trash bag that you you throw away
i wanted them to say this is mines and
they could decorate it how they want it
put stickers on it um and my boys work
because i had to figure out what boys
wanted what do boys want so they like oh
they have to have cars they have to have
toy cars and they have to have like
action figures so my boys were like
lego set yeah yes the lego sets so the
list got longer and longer they're very
um
into everything that that i do as far as
charity and giving so
i
i've been so excited to meet you because
i just admire what you do so much and
guess what to shauna this holiday season
the lego group is celebrating the joy of
building and bringing families together
and because they want to help you
continue to build your business the lego
group and the drew barrymore show are
giving you ten thousand dollars
[Applause]
and i can't think of anyone more
deserving but what excites me is this
includes a lot of people as well the
lego group has launched their build to
give initiative and they're encouraging
people to simply
build a brick-built star and post a
photo of it on social media using the
hashtag
build to give
and then they're going to help children
in need and provide lego sets to them
reaching 1.5 million children
you can visit a lego retail store for
some truly meaningful experiences
thank you
[Music]
you